[Music]
have you been able to get your covet 19
jab yet
many countries are rolling out the covet
19 vaccines
so that the pandemic will be over and we
can get back to normal
how would a vaccine affect your body
how long would it take to build up
immunity to covet 19
if you've never had coven 19 your body
doesn't know how to fight it off
vaccines help
train your immune system to recognize
the virus
and be ready to attack but as we all
have different
immune systems we respond differently to
the vaccine
and the virus having side effects
has nothing to do with the effectiveness
of the vaccine
so let's see what's going on once you
get the jab
[Music]
congratulations you've just had your
first dose
of the covet 19 vaccine for this episode
we'll be focusing on
messenger rna or mrna vaccines
once it enters your body the mrna
vaccine
instructs your cells to create a spike
protein this simulates part of the
sars cov2 viral structure and tricks
your body
into believing that it's been infected
the spike proteins
will then head to the surface of your
cell
your immune cells will detect these
proteins that don't belong
and begin making antibodies
if you happen to catch the virus in the
future these antibodies will attach to
the spike proteins on
both your infected cells and the
coronavirus
this will mark them for immediate
termination by
your immune cells to be clear the mrna
does not
change your dna in any way hear what i
say
once the spike proteins are made your
body
destroys the mrna but
are there any side effects you should be
worried about
five minutes after your vaccine shot
you'll feel some soreness in your arm
to be safe the centers for disease
control recommends you stay
at the vaccination site for at least 15
minutes
in case of a severe reaction while it's
rare
you could have anaphylaxis which is an
immediate
allergic response it causes a series of
symptoms
such as hives or swelling thankfully
trained healthcare personnel will be
available at
every vaccination site to treat you
immediately with epinephrine
and according to the cdc you have a
greater chance of being struck by
lightning around 1 in 500 000
than having an allergic reaction
four hours after your vaccine you could
feel nothing at all lucky you but
you could also get a slight headache or
a low-grade fever
and feel tired this is perfectly normal
and
it's a sign that your immune system has
kicked into action
at this point you may experience mild
symptoms as your body
acclimatizes to the vaccine you might
feel
tired and feverish be sure to get some
rest and
take the day off work if you need to
after about 48 hours you should start to
feel normal again
so let's keep going
okay if you got the pfizer or moderna
vaccine
you'd need to get your second booster
shot three to four weeks after the first
dose
your immune system would be stronger
than the first time but
let's see how it goes next
[Music]
after your second dose you might feel
crummy again
you could feel tired feverish and you
might get the chills
these reactions are more common after
the second dose of the vaccine
but they're mainly mild to moderate and
usually go away in a day or two
[Music]
and two weeks after your second shot
you'd be fully vaccinated against the
covet 19 virus
so far the pfizer beyond tech vaccine
has been 95 percent effective
at preventing covet 19 illness in either
case
the vaccine can prevent hospitalization
and
death in people who have gotten sick
so getting a vaccine is your safest path
to protect yourself
your family and your community against
this virus
it could also help reach herd immunity
by
having vaccinated people act as a
barrier between
non-vaccinated people and those who have
been infected
this video was a collaboration between
nucleus medical media
and the what if channel where we usually
dive into hypothetical scenarios on the
human body
humanity the planet and the cosmos
check out our channel by visiting the
link in the description below